the movie opens in the Pacific
Northwestern town of noo California
where many fishermen have their
livelihood endangered due to a new
salmon caner business being executed
while many towns people welcome this
change a local fisherman named Johnny
Eagle opposes the caner advocating for
the preservation of independent
businesses one day a representative of
the caner named Hank Slattery confronts
Johnny expressing his biased aggression
and asserting that the community fails
to comprehend the potential benefits of
the new business according to him the
business will make their life more
prosperous in the future just look at
all the good Disney McDonalds and
Starbucks have done for all the people
in the world in the next scene we see a
group of fishermen led by a guy named
deak fishing in the middle of the ocean
sensing that they caught something in
the netting of their boat they pull the
Rope however the content seems to be so
heavy that their old broken down ship
can't pull it up as a result deck
summons his young son to give him a hand
and and the crew manually starts pulling
the Rope as the boat shakes a gas can
falls down pouring it all over the deck
eventually the Mast breaks down causing
deck's sun to fall into the water before
deck can do anything his son is dragged
under the Surface by something unseen
soon after the water turns bloody red
which sets the entire crew into a panic
another fisherman prepares a flare gun
but he slips and shoots it accidentally
into the deck which is soaked with
gasoline as a result of this the vessel
bursts into flames and explodes
everybody on board is killed and that
guy who shot the flare is fired the
other Town's people witnessed the
explosion and assumed that a leak caused
the accident we were then introduced to
a couple named Jim Hill and Carol who
are discussing the same blast incident
with the town sheriff in the midst of
this their dog walks out to the woods
where it is confronted by an unseen
creature the dog starts barking but this
creature attacks and kills it
mercilessly later on the couple realizes
that their dog has gone missing and
start to search for it only to discover
its dismembered corpse on the nearby
Beach the next day we learned that
several other dogs have been killed in
similar fashion this monster is an
the scene then shifts again to a
teenage girl named Peggy Larson
preparing for the annual Salmon Festival
the dumbest Festival of them all during
this time she hears a strange noise from
outside she inspects the door but finds
no one frightened she goes to the
kitchen and arms herself with a fork for
self-defense it's not going to do
she then cautiously starts inspecting
the house until she is startled by her
boyfriend Jerry
Potter who is about to cast in gorgio on
the salmon in his pants believing that
he was the one joking with her the
entire time Peggy brushes off her
concern the pair then get ready and
drive to the festival but instead of
entering the event venue they start
making out in the car as the event
begins the president of canco a big
canning business organization named
Charles Bordan takes Center Stage to
deliver a brief speech he announces his
vision to erect one of their
manufacturing plants in the town
emphasizing the consequential creation
of much needed employment opportunities
he also introduces his esteemed Special
Assistant James Edwards and his
accomplished associate Dr Susan Drake to
the assembly in a commitment to progress
Charles pledges to discover Innovative
methods to enhance the size quality and
abundance of salmon however the the
unfolding event is abruptly disrupted by
Johnny who is carrying his dead dog in
his hands he blames Hank for it and
threatens all the town's people to take
back the lands that are rightfully his
preventing the construction of the
canning Factory the ensuing tension
erupts into a physical altercation
between Johnny and Hank creating a scene
amidst the event best salmonfest ever
after some time the town sheriff
intervenes with authority effectively
taking control of the situation the
following day Jerry and Peggy are are
enjoying their romantic time together on
the beach they run around for a while
and then go for a swim however their
happiness is shortlived as Jerry is
abruptly pulled beneath the water's
surface Peggy initially dismisses the
occurrence as a playful prank but she is
soon confronted with a harrowing sight
the mutilated remains of her boyfriend
whose petronus didn't do this
scares her heart out prompting her to
let out a loud scream she desperately
tries to make it to the beach but she is
attacked and dragged onto the Sand by a
monstrous figure this humanoid entity
then tears off her swimming suit and
forces okay back in the town Hank
assembles a group of men to discuss how
to thwart Johnny's efforts they seem to
be aware of Johnny's legal way of hiring
the best lawyers and taking his case to
the court Hank asserts that if Johnny
gets successful in this they will never
be able to establish their canery
business in town after a long discussion
they come up with a plan to blow up
Johnny's residence the next evening two
more teens are camping on on the same
Beach they are about to get intimate
when the same humanoid monster claws its
way inside and kills the boy on the spot
before chasing the girl although she
manages to outpace her as salent
momentarily she ultimately runs into the
clutches of another humanoid figure who
throws her to the sand and gets fishy
with it in the meantime Hank and his
accompli proceed to Johnny's House
executing their plan by launching a
Molotov cocktail just as they thought it
sets the entire place on fire seeing
this Johnny and his friend Tommy attempt
to combat The Blaze while his girlfriend
Linda rushes to seek assistance however
there are more things to worry about
than fighting fires because the humanoid
monsters launch their attack Tommy is
tossed into the water and is on the
verge of drowning witnessing the dire
situation Johnny wields his axe against
the creature but it proves too late as
Tommy has already succumbed to severe
injuries on the other hand Linda is
driving when she is suddenly attacked by
the humanoid figure resulting in the
vehicle crashing and exploding in the
morning Johnny brings Tommy's dead body
at the port and tells all the onlookers
that it was sea monsters Hank who does
not want to disclose his involvement FS
agreement with Johnny's narrative
wanting to get to the bottom of all this
Jim gathers a small team including Dr
Drake in order to hunt down the
so-called monsters upon receiving all
the details from Johnny Dr Drake
believes that these creatures are
nocturnal predators and that they
probably hide during the daytime judging
by its size she speculates that these
creatures must be in the ocean at the
moment in the next scene Jim Johnny and
Dr Drake board a boat and make their way
into the sea after wandering for a while
they come across several caves on the
coastline Dr Drake senses something am
Miss and suggests that they go to
inspect it in detail armed with a
shotgun and crossbow the trio then
Ventures into the cave where they soon
find a nest housing baby monsters as the
creatures approach them Jim guns down
all of them one after another continuing
their exploration they stumble upon a
partially buried leg in the mud upon
removing the mud they are shocked to
discover that it is Peggy who is still
alive but severely traumatized in the
aftermath of this event the three of
them transport a baby Monster to Dr
Drake's clinic for thorough examination
while Peggy is admitted to the hospital
Dr Drake enlightens Jim and Johnny about
the advanced characteristics of these
creatures including remarkable brain
capacity webbed hands and gills at this
point in time Dr Drake finally reveals
that their company was carrying out a
secret experiment on something called
DNA 5 intended to stimulate growth
hormones by experimenting with tadpoles
they were able to make a frog grow full
size in a matter of days she goes on to
disclose that they applied this same
technique to some salmon but
unfortunately these fishies escaped from
Cano's laboratory facility into the
ocean during a storm and were eaten by
large fish subsequently mutating into
the brutal depraved humanoids that have
begun to wreak havoc on the village
according to her this creature can
evolve to four growth stages in one
lifetime starting out as a fish and
ending up as a human she speculates that
these humanoid creatures will attack
more people because they perceive humans
as competitors fish dicks versus Drake
this is getting good recognizing the
urgency of the situation Jim Dr Drake
and Johnny hasten to warn the town's
people amid the ongoing celebration of
the Annual Festival event but by the
time they arrive there it is already too
late as the area is already under attack
the humanoid creatures relentlessly
murder every man and assault Every Woman
they can grab creating a mass chaos
people frantically run here and there in
a desperate bid to save themselves from
these monsters in the midst of this
commotion Jim and Dr Drake noticed that
the humanoid creatures are emerging from
the water and devise a plan to stop them
they take a boat into the water and pour
gasoline and crude oil intending to set
the humanoids Ablaze and cut off their
Retreat it turns out that these humanoid
monsters possess a critical
vulnerability they cannot endure more
than 10 minutes without access to water
due to this they eventually start to get
weaker so the Mob Of Towns folk begin to
gang up against the humanoids they then
shoot beat and burn all of them to death
at one point Hank sustains a severe
injury and comes very very close to
death at the hands of one of the
humanoids thankfully Johnny intervenes
in the nick of time and rescues him from
the clutches of the humanoids this
incident finally resolves the gaps
between the two of them nothing sets
aside the old differences like almost
getting by a fish man meanwhile a
bunch of humanoid creatures show up at
Jim's residence where Carol is alone
with her little boy sensing the
impending danger she immediately locks
up all doors and windows she also hides
her son in a room and then arms herself
with a kitchen knife not long after the
monster breaks in through the window
prompting Carol to stab it multiple
times when another creature charges
towards her she sprays its face with
pepper and then stabs it to death
shortly after this intense confrontation
she hears a knock on the door despite
being scared she cautiously proceeds to
open the door with the knife in hand
only to discover that it is her husband
this finally enables her to breathe a
sigh of relief the morning after the
carnival Mayhem everything seems about
to return to normal as the creatures are
all dead and the town begins to clean up
the damage Jim returns to the scene and
asks the sheriff about Dr Drake's
whereabouts the sheriff informs him that
she has returned to her research lab in
the final scene Dr Drake is seen
alongside the pregnant Peggy who is
already in labor suddenly her monstrous
humanoid Offspring violently bursts
forth from her stomach resulting in a
gruesome Fountain of blood the movie
ends as everyone in the room scream
in Terror subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching